want to make a statement and you can do
just that at neon cactus vintage owners
nagar hosseini and alicia avery are here
to talk about some of the vintage wares
they offer as well as the benefits of
shopping vintage thank you so much for
being here thank you for having us thank
you very much i was just telling you
guys that i was looking through your
website and your social media photos and
everything is just so colorful and
vibrant and fun so is that the vibe
you're going for what do people you know
what can they expect when they come into
the store that is definitely the vibe
statement pieces bold something that
encompasses you as an individual so you
can make a statement i'm all about a
good statement and we will get to those
close behind you in a second here but i
want to talk about some of these fun
items we have on the table in front of
us so you guys don't just have apparel
you have a little bit of everything
right that's right we've got home goods
we even have some furniture items in our
shop so we've got a little something for
everybody and is everything vintage or
gently used or how do you guys describe
it most of the items are vintage
my wife and i sourced to find them and
you can find items that are as old as
for instance this decanter set from the
1920s or as new as let's say the 90s
i can't take my eye off this this is
absolutely beautiful and you guys are
located in downtown las vegas which i
feel like is just this up-and-coming
area now and people are starting to
really appreciate vintage and shopping
locally and is that what you guys are
just kind of encouraging people to feel
when they come in absolutely we love our
community and we love it when they come
through our shop and find something that
represents themselves authentically that
they can wear about their lives so i was
looking at this clothing rack when you
guys walked in and i got to tell you i
i'm drawn to anything sparkly and beaded
so can you please hold up that jacket
for us i need to see what this is it's
beautiful wonderful 100 vegas right yes
so this is just one of many things here
i'll hold on to that right yeah because
i am just obsessed with this can you
guys just show a few of your other
favorites and what people can find when
they come in the store right we have um
anything from 90s graphic tees we've got
this really cool unlv shot um here and
then some different prints we've got
patterned skirts from the 80s
cool sets from the 90s just really
anything you're looking looking for we
also have like staple coats
i love it okay i need this jacket i need
this to canter i'm just going to stay
and you know hang out and shop amongst
myself don't mind me i mean for people
who want to come out and check the store
out where can they find you guys we are
at ferguson's downtown and we're open
wednesday through sunday
usually eleven to five so you can come
down and shop we bring in new inventory
weekly oh ooh even more all right i love
ferguson's too it's such a fun area to
hang out in and i know what i'll be
looking for so thank you guys so much
for being here be sure to check out the
store they have awesome stuff jc i'll
send it over to you i want the